put in the work so one week 63 of the
book and super excited to be now in the
launch mode you know selling getting
some traction getting some results
getting tons of emails getting lots of
support it's been exciting and
overwhelming I know we're just getting
started up you can see you know the book
is now making product shots in some of
the videos one of the things that you
have to understand you turn any project
is how much work it's going to be and
one of my advisors who's helped me in
the market in the book suggested when
you look at my bonus packages for
somebody buys one book he said can you
give them some kind of access to you can
you give them even just a thank you
video like I have to do a thank you
video for every person that buys the
book it's crazy but I said yeah like if
that'll make a difference i'm going to
do it and so this morning before coming
here I was recording Thank You videos
for people who have purchased a book
it's not being afraid of the work right
you have to put in the work to make it
happen for those of you who are just
looking for an easy way out if you're
just looking for how do i make money
super quick you might want to move on to
something else right and I enjoy the
work too right i'm making all these
videos thanking people you know it says
five seconds that i usually go on and
you know say something about where
they're from or some kind of story
something in there by or their website
don't count on it though just for you
guys who are looking at it you know i
might just stick to the five-second
thing but being willing to put in the
work and not just seeing it as work
right seeing it as something that's
adding value and helping out and looking
forward to it i think not enough
entrepreneurs do that I think too many
times think oh I gotta go and do more of
this and if that's the mentality that's
the mindset you may be doing the wrong
thing like you should enjoy the work
that you're putting in and be willing to
work the hard hours and not just see it
as work and so hopefully you can apply
that to the business your business and
what you're going through so I want to
get to the questions first up Tamra
weeks Tamra bought 10 copies of the book
I love it she was the first one that I
made a question when you get 10 copies
you get a question and I make a custom
video just for you and she was the first
one so I'm excited thank you for
answering my question thank you for
explaining how are you
on the bestseller list I was wondering
how many books you've sold it's
interesting that you can't find out any
other way than through email receipts
thank you for sharing so much in details
that you don't really have to share with
us your openness is appreciated and I
learned so much from you I love the idea
of a live stream launch publisher mark
and a car j'ai RI Stephen yeah so the
idea of the 3000 book sold was to get on
the bestseller list and that's why the
authors are doing so many presales yeah
I guess I don't have to tell you that
information but that's I've never seen
another author say that either but
that's part of this series and as part
of if you want to write a book and
you're trying to get that status I'm
trying to be open and share that with
you and I'm sure my publisher is like
not super happy with everything i'm
sharing but that's part of the process
of dealing with me i guess in terms of
how many books i've sold what i want to
do is have a countdown it's an update
every week that shows and hopefully we
can update that every week for you guys
you can see how we're doing and then
turn to the live stream i'm gearing up I
like that idea more more so that on
december six when the book launches i
have some guests on people that you know
and some people who you may not have net
maybe my parents will want to jump on to
and share some believe or maybe share
some embarrassing evarin stories i will
soon bless your rosanna rosanna is here
rosanna sneezed we're saying bless you
next up is milena who wrote in the say
I've received the bonuses from your book
they are already ah some thank you I
appreciate that thank you so much
writing this book I can feel that your
book is going to help me find the last
key that is missing in my whole me
business life entrepreneurship my one
word I'm looking for it since a year now
turn them around changing deleting your
help will be good Spain is waiting for
you thank you for that love i really
appreciate it we did put a lot of work
into the bonuses the idea what the bonus
is too as i wanted to have something
this is you know maybe lesson for you
guys too if you're if you have something
kind of in the distant future that
you're trying to sell now to give
something that people can get access to
now so yes the book comes out in
december but we want to have something
that people can use now get value from
now and pack it full of value so that
even if you didn't get the book even if
we weren't selling anything but the
bonuses the bonuses would be worth you
know 10 times the value of what you're
putting down the amount that you're
investing and so I'm glad that you like
the bonuses every tier has scaling
bonuses so that there's more more value
and more of my time
22 and it's really encouraging hear you
say and I kind of always felt that you
know when we create the package like
this is awesome value but it's great
that it's great to hear you guys say
that you like the Valiants coming back
and thank you for ordering two next up k
yanta smith 42 million dollars mistake
in my first business we had an
opportunity to get acquired and we were
too late to the party we had our
blinders on we're going down one path on
business that we thought was the right
path but we didn't spend enough time
actually talking to customers talking to
partners and that was the biggest
mistake I probably made in my
professional career and then by the time
we got out to market and realize it was
this big opportunity to get our company
acquired we were we were a last-second
addition to the discussion and we just
didn't have enough and so they bought
our competitor out instead of us for 42
million dollars if we knew about that
deal sooner if we had listened more if
we've been better prepared we could have
made adjustments and we might have made
that deal we had a lot of the things
that they needed just not enough for the
other things and so we lost that deal it
hurts today it hurts but that that
drives you for right that that make sure
I don't make that mistake again and so
thank you thank you for bringing it up
again thank you for bringing it up again
relaxing sleep station I just wanted to
add that I'm waiting for the audiobook
version keep pressuring me I mean this
should have been done already getting
the Arabic version or getting shipping
in different countries and we're looking
at multi-link although that's not quite
ready yet that probably after the the
launch but the audio version should have
been up and it's it's really frustrating
that it's not so every time you guys
write in to say i want the audio version
I forward that to my publisher and say
let's get this going these guys want it
so if you really want the audio version
and it's not up yet leave a comment
below so i can forward it out to my
publisher and say what's going on these
people need it so it flies a little bit
more pressure for them to next up paul
thompson audio i will be getting I
promise there will be a huge feedback I
love it keep the pressure come and keep
the audio pressure come on I want to
forward it all to the publisher next up
Rishi Cup TV Evan you are believed
personified I respect that you don't
want to be too heavy-handed to sell the
book on every video this is why we trust
you so many people flock your channel
because we know that for you it's not
about the money but the mission
nevertheless we want to help you
make a huge impact my question is for
those of us believe nation folk what are
some other ways you can start giving
value back to you after we buy the book
what else can you support this book
campaign choose and thank you cup of
give back I really appreciate that Rishi
I've started to incorporate the book a
little bit more on to the videos you
know we have the product placement and
these are the special galley addition
because they're actually going to be
hard cover not these soft cover I don't
even know if we're ever going to go soft
cover so these will that's all that ever
existed these things thank you for the
question in terms of support I think
it's you know being able to spread the
message tell people about it if you if
you bought it already found value in the
bonuses telling your friends you know
putting out social media again where
where you feel it makes sense right just
like I don't want to be too over the top
and every videos like bye bye bye bye
bye I don't want you to feel like you
have to go sell your friends on this
stuff but if it comes up in conversation
we feel like it might be beneficial
helpful to them then I always appreciate
the plug you do a great job reaching on
the League of Legends stream that we
have together popping in the book
whenever you feel it's appropriate I
think you probably hype up the book more
in those videos than I do and so I
appreciate that so you don't free those
are you guys watching if you feel like
there's a fit to talk about the book or
if you want me to have you know come on
and be a guest on your show or you see
some kind of opportunity then I really
appreciate that but you know I don't
want you to feel uncomfortable in
promoting it or feeling like you have to
talk about it because that would that's
not the intent of what I'm trying to
create next up shalonda who wrote in the
say boom next up Manjunath waiting for
the book anyways hardcover version is
unavailable in Amazon that I in for
pre-order hopefully we'll look into it
so it's another thing if you guys are
from another country and you're looking
at getting the book and you're having
trouble it's not there shipping is too
expensive let me know give me a hard
time leaving in all the comments because
I want to forward that off to my
publisher as well if we get a lot of
people from a Margaret saying hey we
want the book I can then apply that
pressure to them to say hey listen
people want to buy the book from this
area and we can look at ways to make it
easier next up Bradley who wrote in the
say hey Evan how come you were a ring on
your thumb actually don't wear a ring on
my thumb it's usually on one of my two
but when I'm when I'm thinking or
chatting or talking I play with I fidget
and so I play with the ring and I've
worn it actually so much on my left
thumb that I have a little callous
developing here on the side because I
push it down and when I'm thinking I
guess I word on my left thumb more than
more than that so I don't know I I like
to have something in my hand that helps
me think so I do this a lot I put out my
thumb a lot so if you watch my
livestream for these videos you know you
may see that every now and then Nina
gets upset at me when it's not on my
ring finger but it's so loose that it
slides off super easily so i have to
wear it on my right side but then when
i'm playing and when i'm on the computer
using my mouse it bothers me so i switch
it around but really the truth is when
I'm talking I like to fidget and play
with my hands and do something so having
the ring makes it easy and so mm-hmm
sometimes it's on my thumb next up chef
ich launch party idea have a gathering
at a venue in Toronto chapters as
possible because it's Canadian that's
live streams as well that's an
interesting idea most of my audience is
not in Toronto but I may do some live
events in the city or in other cities as
I might travel a couple cities to see
you guys and do live stream I'd also
love to do some of these videos like the
top 10 in espresso with some of you guys
on it sharing your thoughts and opinions
and maybe reading the couple lines we'll
see but still keep the ideas coming it's
still a while away but I appreciate it
appreciate the love and we'll probably
end up doing something in Toronto
whether it's not a chapter XIV the Wi-Fi
connection sucks though so it's hard to
do a live stream but whether we do it
there we do it here at Toronto dance
salsa we'll figure it out next up is
William your camera work is pure art
well I can't take credit for the camera
work that's Jason hain behind the camera
Jason you want to come in you're gonna
come in and say hi no he doesn't want to
say hi Rihanna's gonna bring him in
Rosanna is gonna bring him in she's
trying now he's he's he's he's walking
away is what that's him laughing though
he's too handsome for the key might just
break the lens he's so handsome well
thank you for that feedback he'd made
Jason smile and very happy and I think
it's important to you guys to surround
yourself with the team that kind of
amplifies your strength so Jason Jason
walked in here saying
was the what did you say Jason you were
the best way best videographer in Canada
[ __ ] lost No Oh Rosanna agrees with
that Rosanna saw his work for the first
time that wasn't my channel and she was
blown away Jason hain kaam you can see
all the other footage that he's done
some awesome high-end looking stuff so
I'm sure he'll appreciate it even though
he's being shy right now my goal is to
one day get him on it on a video if you
guys want to see Jason on a video
leaving the comments below and one day
we will get him in front of the camera
not just behind it next up Wesley hello
Evan thank you so much for sharing your
knowledge with us quick question do you
plan a giveaway of the book for the
YouTube subscribers thank you have an
amazing day I don't know that I'm doing
giveaways to the book I think with each
of the book purchases and sales we're
doing bonuses so there's different bones
packages you can get as well as doing
shoutouts in different videos so you
guys get some traction in some exposure
and just you know get your name here on
the believe nation channel and last
question from a Scholastic definitely
would love if you can have the sit-down
interview featuring your agent and
publisher it would help me or others
wanting to know the in-depth process of
the behind the scenes and what it truly
takes to bring a book like yours of the
forefront it would be fun to see an
actual agent or publisher be part since
we normally don't really get a chance to
pick their brains and ask questions so
it's really cool feedback I think the
three people would be my manager who
helps me book deals and he's based in
New York and he introduced me to my to
the publishing world into the agent I
have my literary agent Nina who is an
ene and I'm maraton and I na so Nina is
a literary agent and she helped
introduce me to the different publishers
and so I recommend working with a lit a
junt if your goal is to try to get a
good deal for yourself and then Marion
who is at penguin Random House who can
answer your perspective of what the
publisher deals with so i might do three
different sessions i'll have to see most
of them are pretty behind the scenes and
pretty shy I think Nina's done one
interview I don't know about Steve and
Marion but you know what if you guys are
leaving some comments let's see some
comments okay we got Steve the manager
Nina any and
a the literary agent and Marion the
publisher give me comments that you want
to see Steve Nina and Marion and i'll
forward to them and say listen believe
nation wants to talk with you let's set
something up that'd be pretty cool and
Jason too don't forget Jason we need to
have Jason on so sit for this week sorry
couldn't get to all the questions I
appreciate everything that's come in
thank you guys so much for watching
thank you guys so much for supporting
the book I love to know what you think
about the topic at the start of the day
which was put in the work and doing the
work that you love and enjoy the process
if you have a question about my book or
the book writing process that might help
you leave in the comments below I'll
make sure to try to answer it in next
week's video and last but not least I
want to give a quick shadow to Ricardo
THC who ordered my book Ricardo thank
you so much I really appreciate it
Ricardo some siena italy i love siena
have been there once super fun people
awesome little city so hopefully i'll be
able to make it back Ricardo Mila Grazia
so if you guys want to get a shadow in a
future video just like Ricardo did make
sure you pick up a copy of the book and
email in your receipt that's how we keep
track guys make sure your email in your
receipt so we can keep track and maybe
we'll see you in a future video and
that's it for this week thank you guys
so much for watching and continue to
believe or whatever your one word is and
i'll see you soon